remember what happened on November 16
2001 by any chance first Harry Potter
films - you were 18 years to the day Wow
no I'm saying yeah so no I know does it
feel like it's been quite that long a
very strange current relationship to
that I just start to watch I saw the
first one recently well we'll wait you
just saw the first you definitely you
haven't seen any of the other films no
why it's nice I don't know it's because
you don't like watching yourself for
what I tell me he's completely that he's
just I don't know it was it was a period
of my life where he kind of watch us go
up there all the kind of like awkward
teenager stages it's it's not something
I've ever really wanted to revisit this
very much it was a great experience I've
got great memories but I don't yeah you
left it and you think fondly of it by
doing is that something you think should
you have kids one day that you would
like to sit down and let them watch it
or yeah yeah yeah it is this is quite
surreal thought but yeah no of course
absolutely there was a huge part my life
and it's a huge and like you said not
just you obviously you were growing up
on the big screen but as an audience
member so many people millions of people
watched you grew up and watched Ann and
Emma sure it's just kind of it's cool to
see where you all are now which is a
really beautiful thing you know that
being said though this is a time where a
lot of things are getting rebooted
remade revisited do you feel like Harry
Potter's some things that could ever be
revisited I don't know I guess so yeah I
mean what kind of having Star Wars and
things again I mean it could find
another
another Lisa live on it and it has I
mean with the play there's a play and
I'm talking you Dan it's like make a
pact to say if one of us does it then
all of us has to do it but I'm in a
minute pax but I think it'll be it's
kind of ended at such a good time I
think it was everyone was kind of ready
to finish and it was an amazing period
of our lives but I think none of us
would be King to jump back into it just
yet
but you never I mean never say never I
mean I love playing that character I I
feel a very close kind of affiliation
with him so well we all feel a close
affiliation with you guys as well and
it's so crazy like I feel like we're
hearing more and more in particular
about Emma Watson and Tom how thing have
you heard about this allegedly they're
dating or maybe like their self
partnering they're both self partnering
okay could you ever see the two of them
together yeah kid it was always
something you think that will be the
spark
I doubt it what I don't want to start
anything but did anyone's date like
while you guys were filming no no really
but you saw some sparks there's some
sparks but we would keep you engaged
like it any current yeah playground kind
of flare taste romances yeah did you
have any sparks for anyone just have any
sparks
Rupert's that was spark free well
congrats on this series thank you have
you guys seen it from start to finish
yet no we've seen them we sort of
watched the first episode yeah that we
were kind of like yeah what did you
think
initial impression you know what I
actually don't think I could keep a kid
because I was so like I was just I fight
really hard to watch myself so I was
kind of squirming but we will watch it
properly at the premiere and then I'll
be able to give more but people seem to
really like it what do you think yeah no
it's I don't know I always find it quite
difficult to myself yeah just being in
it and filming it you could feel this
it's just a very it's quite a big topic
to kind of be dealing with
is quite heavy and quite dark but it has
also these elements are kind of surreal
and humor as well so it's kind of got a
bunch of yeah a lot of different little
elements in there which is really
fascinating I feel like Tony and night
they do that so well you know but that
baby doll it was terrifying
so was it equally as terrifying if not
more looking at it on set
pretty creepy yeah pretty creepy yeah
yeah and they were like stickers of it
around Saturday that was there was a
bunch of scary Jerry mom [ __ ] let's jump
to another topic where either of you
because now you play the nanny the
sitter of sorts so have either of you
not even played but have you been a
babysitter or nanny and real-life -
family babysat once or twice a couple of
times - like an antenna back in London
uh-huh but I've never been like a
full-time nanny or anything like that
but yeah I babysat a few times yeah
Rupert doesn't even trusted you with
their kids yeah baby yeah baby yeah I've
done I'm on a five so I used to cop to
me where do you fall notice the oldest
of so yeah Brother Bear had to take care
of the rest
have you guys ever had like a creepy
nanny or babysitter situation quite like
nails character luckily no and he never
encountered something quite this creepy
yeah no all of my baby says when I was
little was so cool they were weird yeah
I went to a Catholic school was a few
few teachers a bit like yeah no yeah no
nothing quite like no nothing quite like
this all right um so neither of you guys
have kids just yet yourselves but this
series did it perhaps change your
perspective or outlook on having kids
eventually
it's not it's not great it's not
I mean I'm 20 so I'm very much focused
on the career right now because on
myself
yeah yes and but yeah no I'm not I'm not
really thinking about kids just yet but
I've always wanted them so this hasn't
deterred me yeah yeah I just probably
won't hire a nanny
ya know see ya mmm it doesn't make you
think about kind of being a dad and and
I think a lot of people watching the
show I think every this in this
situation how pregnant all kids okay I
want to just finally wrapping up with a
series and everything how do you feel
like audiences should Benj the show
should they see you know when three come
out all three at the same time should
they watch with the lights on the lights
off they watch with a group should they
watch alone watch it however you like I
think it's gonna be scary but accessible
and I think watching with the lights out
and you know get ready yeah because the
half-hour episode you have an unusual
thing yeah you can just
[Music]